welcome back it is 6 41 giving students
a bigger and better stage Liberty High
School's show choir would like to show
off their skills but you know the thing
is people can't really see that so now
the students are trying to raise money
so that everybody can get a better view
Lorna Grady is live at Liberty High
School this morning down in Silverado
Ranch with the story Lauren good morning
to you
good morning yes we've had a great day
kind of just showing me the the numbers
here obviously and then their dance
moves and their singing it sounds great
and like I said they're campaigning and
fundraising to be able to have that same
setup in their theater room I'm joined
by one of the seniors here Maxie so talk
to me about um why you like show choir
um show choir is just like a completely
different experience than
um every other choir like we're
obviously singing and dancing and
there's more of a connection with
everybody so it's more of a family and
we like can always count on each other
and it's just an amazing thing and again
fundraising for the platforms tell me
about the the why that's so necessary
um so like the last three years we've
only had a couple and people are like
off the sides and people can like close
to falling off of them sometimes so
having that full set would make
um choreography and everything so much
easier and safer for the whole program
definitely water wall definitely uh
easier yeah so while speaking on that
once you get in there and show me some
moves here the Patriot Stars once again
this morning guys
[Music]
wow again
so again we've got donation information
for you on our website 8newsnow.com live
here with the student Florida back to
you guys
that's it that is so amazing the kids
are great and Lauren was hanging in
there with them too oh that's fantastic
oh congratulations to them let's get
them their risers there you go me